With all the chaos in Gotham City, it isn't
shocking that a few mistakes have been made
by the filmmakers who've brought the Dark
Knight to the big screen.
So, what are some of the biggest mistakes
lurking in the Batman movies?
Caught red-handed
When the Joker orders his cronies to destroy
everything in Gotham's museum during Tim Burton’s
Batman, one henchman gleefully smacks a bunch
of red handprints all over a painting.
But in the very next frame, the graffiti has
magically disappeared, and he’s back to
defacing a painting from earlier.
Moms everywhere would probably like to know
where he got those washable paints.
Joker’s bloody chin
Moments before he plummets from a helicopter,
the Joker is visibly bloody from his mouth
to his chin.
And although the fall kills him, a close-up
shot reveals it somehow did miracles for his
beauty regimen.
Selina’s rearranging kitchen
Single lady Selina Kyle is in such a rush
when she runs out of her apartment that she
forgets to put the milk back in the fridge.
But when she returns after her little accident,
the carton is nowhere to be seen and the dishes
in the drying rack are moved around, too.
Did her cats tidy up, or did the milk have
an even weirder night than she did?
That’s not the only weird thing going on
in her apartment.
Soon after that scene, Selina starts to assemble
her Catwoman costume, brandishing a pair of
blue scissors.
Or are they pink?
Maybe it’s Maybelline
As Batman prepares to reveal his identity
to Catwoman in Batman Returns, he's seen with
his usual dark eye makeup surrounding his
eyes.
But after a quick cutaway, it's suddenly gone.
This is because he's about to remove his mask,
and apparently, it was about 25 years too
early for this look.
Ivy’s vanishing gloves
Batman and Robin from 1997 had a lot of problems,
and simple continuity was one of them.
Seated in the back of a limousine driven by
Bane, Poison Ivy is clearly wearing black
gloves when she begins to put on a wig.
However, in the next shot, her gloves are
gone...just another victim of Joel Schumacher’s
madness.
The spiked bracelets
That wasn’t the only time Poison Ivy’s
arms were the victim of bad continuity.
She’s wearing thin, leaflike gloves when
she first welcomes Robin into her lair.
But when she angrily pushes him into her gross
swimming pool, she's suddenly wearing spiky
rubber bracelets.
The transporting gun
In Batman Begins, Bruce Wayne is waiting at
the courthouse to shoot Joe Chill, the man
who killed his parents.
A female assassin runs up and pushes a pistol
up against the criminal's chest instead.
And when she shoots a split-second later,
she’s holding the gun at least a foot away.
Not even Batman moves that fast.
"Where are you?!"
"Here."
Joker’s fast hands
During the iconic interrogation scene in The
Dark Knight, the Joker and Batman tangle while
the Gotham City Police Department looks on…
but it seems like they got a little more tangled
than anyone expected.
As Batman holds Joker up against a wall, Joker
holds onto Batman’s arms with a chin-up
grip.
But when the camera angle changes, the Clown
Prince is doing a pull-up instead...before
his hands quickly return to their first position.
The botched headline
Gotham’s copy editors should probably get
fired for this one...or at least the props
department.
In The Dark Knight Rises, Bruce Wayne stumbles
upon a newspaper headline whilst conducting
some online research about the cat burglar
in town, where the word ‘heist’ is clearly
misspelled.
Guess it could have been worse.
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know which
Batman movie mistakes you’ve noticed...